in the united states you'll often hear a
tv meteorologist explain
that tornadoes are a consequence of
large colliding air masses
from canada and the gulf of mexico
but that doesn't tell us very much at
all
these two large air masses are always
pushing against one another
if that were all it is to make a tornado
there would
always be tornadoes the study of tornado
genesis
which is the birth of a tornado tells us
that tornadoes are generated
by storms and moreover by the unique
structure
of each storm those large
colliding air masses are simply the
trigger for the storms
the creation of the tornado is by other
processes
entirely so the science of
tornadogenesis begins with an
understanding of the storm
in particular an understanding of
supercell
dynamics in super cells wind shear in
the lowest mile of the atmosphere is
responsible for creating horizontally
aligned tubes of air a strong low-level
jet
erases over the surface winds creating a
helical
tube of spinning air developing
thunderstorms can
tilt a tube like this upwards this spin
which was once horizontally aligned is
now twisting
vertically in the updraft the updraft is
now rotating leading to the birth
of the mesocyclone and the supercell
how this process leads to the formation
of a tornado has long been a mystery
but continual research by the best
meteorologist
has discovered the storm-scale processes
that occur within the supercell to
create a tornado
a precursor to the formation of a
tornado is the appearance of a wall
cloud
the wall cloud forms at the base of the
updraft of the supercell
its name is derived from how this cloud
often appears to form
a wall around the tornado the wall cloud
appears to lower itself from the base of
the updraft as the supercell strengthens
however this is just an illusion
in reality the wall cloud builds itself
at lower
and lower altitudes as the supercell
ingests
its own juicy air let's see how this
process
unfolds here's an outline of a supercell
thunderstorm
the mesocyclone forms here and spins its
way upward
through the depth of the troposphere at
the heart of the storm
the reason this updraft appears to be
leaning to the right
is because of the wind shear stronger
winds aloft push the updraft downstream
these same winds create the forward
flank downdraft
this is the front side of the storm
where the majority of the precipitation
falls
falling precipitation in the forward
flank creates a powerful
downdraft as this downdraft air hits the
ground
it splashes outward radially
the air in the downdraft is cool and
nearly saturated
as it collides with the warm moist air
that is flowing toward the storm
the warm air runs right over the top of
the outflow
strong but small scale vertical wind
shear results from this collision
and the result is a tightly spinning
horizontally aligned
tube of air the tail end of this tube
runs just beneath the mesocyclone
here it is once again pulled upward by
the updraft
the wall cloud emerges when this tube of
air is ingested into the storm
it appears as a lowering of the cloud
base because the storm is
actually breathing in its own outflow
the air is very near saturation and as a
result it needs only be lifted a short
distance to cool enough
for condensation to begin the wall cloud
spins faster than the mesocyclone ii
this
is a live look at a wall cloud notice
how low it is to the ground
the mesocyclone is above this outside of
this shot
the forward flank is off to the right
and out of the shot as well
you are getting an up-close view of what
it is like
to go storm chasing watch what happens
over the next few moments do you notice
the cone-shaped cloud feature that has
appeared in the center of the wall cloud
that is the funnel cloud you are
witnessing
tornado genesis where does the tornadic
circulation
originate within the storm well in the
same manner in which the wall cloud
formed
the tornado was born out of the
thunderstorm's other downdraft
the rear flanked downdraft first let's
recall that the mesocyclone the updraft
of the storm
is sandwiched in between the ford flank
downdraft and the rear flank downdraft
now the rear flank downdraft is much
smaller
descending air on the back side of the
storm is pushed against the updraft by
the environmental winds on the back side
of the storm
this downdraft is often composed of
heavy rain and occasionally hail
as this air descends the rear flank
downdraft
curls around the mesocyclone producing
the familiar
hook shape on radar check out this radar
image which shows the hook echo
and rear flank of the storm
just like the forward flank downdraft
this descending air hits the ground
and splashes outward radially from the
top
down both outflow boundaries spread and
intersect
near the updraft the forward flank has
already created the wall cloud
let's discover how the rear flank
creates the tornado
the outflow in the rear flank creates
yet another tube of
spinning air that is horizontally
aligned being so
close to the uptrack this tube is pulled
upward by the strong vertical winds
within the wall cloud
and mesocyclone the tube of air
bends and bows upward creating two
vertically aligned
tubes of air the one located nearest the
updraft
rotates counterclockwise while the other
which is closest to your to you in this
figure
rotates clockwise each tube is capable
of producing a tornado however
the clockwise spinning tube often
dissipates
or is sheared apart leaving only the
counterclockwise spinning tube
this tube of air is then stretched
vertically as it is pulled upwards by
the mesocyclone
stretching tightens the rotation causing
it to spin
faster by the conservation of angular
momentum
the tornado is born as this tube of air
is stretched
again tornado genesis is much more
complicated
than cold air from canada hitting warm
air from the gulf
tornadoes are formed out of the small
scale circulations
within the storm itself after all
many supercells are unable to go through
the entire process
all three events must line up at the
right time
and location for the tornado to form
only about 30 percent
of all supercells are able to produce
tornadoes too often the storm's outflow
both forward and rear are not in the
ideal configuration
to produce a wall cloud or tornadic
circulation
now mid-november is not a typical time
of year for tornadoes
this figure shows the average number of
november tornadoes in each state
however on november 17 2013
everything was aligned in illinois to
produce a severe weather outbreak
one supercell in particular appeared to
have everything in place
this image shows the time evolution of
the supercells that produce the
powerfully destructive washington
illinois tornado
you are seeing a piece of luteria every
15 minutes stitched together in one
image
this single storm produced multiple
tornadoes as it tracked from the
southwest
to the northeast here's a radar
reflectivity image of the storm near
washington illinois supercells have very
recognizable features
let's draw a white outline around the
storm and identify its main parts
first notice the forward flank downdraft
then we can easily find the hail core of
this storm
by looking for high radar reflectivity
this storm produced hailstones as
big as softballs looking again at the
radar reflectivity image
the rear flank downdraft and hook echo
are immediately evident
the powerful tornado was located here
where this hook echo meets the updraft
right in this location while i was
watching this storm unfold
i saw one feature i never want to see
a debris ball the very high radar
reflectivity values in the hook echo
are not from hail these very large
radar echoes are from the tornado
tossing debris
high into the sky where the radar can
scan it
the bright reflectivity is from the
radar beam hitting tree branches
shingles and pieces of siding or lumber
that have been thrown hundreds of feet
into the air by the tornadic winds 190
mile per hour winds can level most
structures
and strip the branches and bark from
large
established trees but as i was looking
through
all the pictures of the damage this
particular picture caught my eye
do you see the swirl marks in the fields
that were cut from this tornado
these marks can only be made by a
multi-vortex tornado
small tornadoes those that are at most a
couple of hundred feet wide
have different internal structure than
those that are much wider
small tornadoes don't produce striations
in the fields like this
the internal structure of a small
tornado is such that the winds in the
center of the tornado
ascend rapidly sucking debris upwards
into the storm
as the tornado strengthens it often gets
wider
and undergoes a process called vortex
breakdown
strong centrifugal forces within the
funnel create an opening in the center
of the tornado
where the air pressure drops off
dramatically
within this opening air descends from
above
and creates a very small downdraft in
the center of the tornado
this downdraft widens the tornado a good
analogy for this process is to imagine
a potter creating a clay bowl on a
potter's wheel
the mound of clay is transformed into a
bowl as the potter pushes
his or her thumbs into the center in the
same way
the tornado's downdraft widens it
fundamental principles in physics tell
us that
as the radius of a rotating system
increases
its velocity will decrease this is
exactly what happens in the tornado
as it widens its rotational winds slow
down
so why does the tornado strengthening
why does this happen when the tornado is
getting wider
tornadoes that widen like this undergo a
process called vortex
breakdown on the edge of the tornado air
is rapidly ascending
in the center it is rapidly descending
where the rising air and sinking air
meet small-scale circulations called
suction vortices form a tornado that
goes through vortex breakdown
essentially breaks apart into several
smaller tornadoes
the larger circulation still exists but
now
embedded within its circulation are
several smaller
tornadoes this is when the tornado is at
its
most dangerous one it is very wide
the large-scale winds are still spinning
at triple digit speeds
and now cover a larger area and two
the suction vortices are spinning at
triple digit speeds themselves
have you ever heard of someone talking
about tornado damage where they say
it destroyed this house but left the one
right next to it almost
undamaged we often thought that
tornadoes could hop around
or slither back and forth like a snake
let me assure you that tornadoes do not
hop and they don't slither back and
forth
like the tornado from the wizard of oz
so where did all these
strange stories come from suction
vortices
are often hidden from view they are
masked by the
by all the dust and debris and
condensation in the tornado
so they are rarely seen there is
evidence of suction vortices
like the picture of the field with all
the striations but it was not until
modern
high-resolution doppler radar began
observing them did we understand how
they formed
and how they destroy things each suction
vortex
may only be 50 to 100 feet wide as it
swirls around
inside the larger tornado it may take
out one home entirely but leave the
neighbor's house
standing look at the path of this
tornado from above
do you notice how straight it is in fact
when we look at damaged photos like this
from nearly
all tornadoes we find them to be quite
straight
this is evidence that tornadoes do not
slide back and forth like many believe
but many of you have probably seen a
picture like this
is it fake i just told you that
tornadoes don't behave like the tornado
from the wizard of oz
well this one is not fake it's a picture
of a tornado in its rope stage
like all other parts of the supercell
the tornado has a life cycle
a telltale sign that a tornado is near
the end of its life
is if it takes on this rope shape
will this tornado slide back to the
other side no
it will simply continue to elongate in
this direction until it shears apart and
dissipates
the reason it takes on this shape is
because the rear flank of the storm has
completely
wrapped itself under the updraft and
kicked the base of the tornado out
from under the mesocyclone it will not
recover from this
the supercell however can recover and
begin a new stage of development
as the rear flank undercuts the main
updraft of the old tornado
a new updraft tends to form to the
southeast of the old one
it forms here because this is where the
warm moist unstable air is found
as the new mesocyclone forms the
supercell has the potential to form
another tornado some supercells can go
through
many cycles and produce a family of
tornadoes
each tornado track begins just a few
miles after the old one ends
and it is offset to the southeast by a
few miles
the november 17 2013 supercell in
illinois produced
five different tornadoes the most
famous tornado family event occurred
during the super outbreak of 1974.
this image shows how several supercells
went through many life cycles
and produced numerous tornadoes look
closely
at the tornado tracks that started south
of decatur illinois
one supercell produced nine different
tornadoes as it tracked from central
illinois to northern indiana
see how their tracks are staggered
supercells can often produce seemingly
incredible tornadic events
check out this picture of the twin wedge
tornadoes
from pilger nebraska in 2014.
there is evidence that these tornadoes
formed from the same supercell as it
cycled the first radar dissipated
shortly after this picture was taken
it is a rare event to see two tornadoes
from the same supercell
spinning in the same direction
now tornadoes can form in non-supercell
storms too
just like the water spout and the land
spout forms a
strong like horizontal wind shear when
they do form
land spouts are typically found along
the leading edge of squall lines
the winds ahead of the squall line just
like the supercell
often come from the southwest in the
united states
behind the leading edge of the squall
line the winds shift quickly and are
often from a westerly direction
these winds cross small
vertically aligned circulations can form
between
and basically be stretched into the
updraft of the squall line
the land spouts that form along the
leading edge of the squall line
are often very weak and rarely produce
damage greater than
that of the squall line itself
tornado-like vortices
also form in fire just like the water
spout and land spout
horizontal windshear can create small
eddies
like a whirlwind the heat from the fire
causes the air to rapidly ascend
this stretches the fiery vortex
vertically causing it to spin
faster sometimes these fiery vortices
can move quickly as they're blown by the
wind
they can easily spread forest fires and
they're incredibly
intensely hot
tornado research is difficult to
properly observe a tornado you must get
close to one
one of nature's most intense expressions
of severe weather
early research was pioneered in the work
of dr
theodore fujita but his work almost
never came to be on august 9
1945 the united states planned to drop
its second of
two nuclear bombs on japan the target
city was kokura
but cloud cover forced the bombers to
abandon the target city and hit the
secondary target a city called nagasaki
a 24 year old ted fujita had just
finished his bachelor's of science and
was working on his doctorate studying
typhoons
his life was spared because of cloud
cover
vegeta studied the blast damage of the
nuclear bomb
now when he immigrated to the united
states he pioneered research and
thunderstorm downbursts
and frequently referenced the
similarities between the damage caused
uh by the nuclear bomb and damage
patterns from downbursts
he recognized that it was nearly
impossible to measure the winds
of turn of a tornado directly the winds
and debris it carried would destroy an
anemometer
rather than trying to measure the winds
directly dr fujita set out
to measure the winds of a tornado by
examining the damage they caused
his original scale had 13 levels
f0 to f12
these levels were created to match
nautical wind speeds measured
by the beaufort scale and aeronautical
speeds measured by the mach scale
the beaufort scale measures the force of
the wind and relates it
to sea conditions such as wave height
and appearance
the mach number is simply a ratio of the
actual speed of an object
over the speed of sound on the original
fujita scale
an f1 was the equivalent of the 12th
value on the beaufort scale and had a
had a speed
approximately 74 miles per hour the same
speed is the minimum wind speed
threshold for a category one strength
hurricane
the chart shows the values of the f
scale
although the scale goes to f12 the f5
category corresponds to wind speeds that
range from 261 miles an hour
to 318 miles per hour in fujita's
research he commented on how difficult
it would be for tornadic winds
to exceed this category therefore this
highest category on the operational f
scale
was a 5. the f scale uses damage to
estimate wind speeds
an experienced survey crew is assigned
to every reported tornado
and the damage they survey is
cross-referenced to vegeta's descriptive
scale
each segment of the tornado is tornado's
path i should say is ranked
but the overall ranking that the tornado
receives corresponds to its worst damage
there were a few drawbacks to this
methodology
what if the tornado didn't hit anything
an f5 tornado would do the same amount
of damage to a plowed cornfield
as an f1 what if the tornado hit poorly
hit a poorly constructed home
it may receive a much higher ranking
simply because it was easier to destroy
what if the survey crew was
inexperienced the subjective scale could
be easily misinterpreted
but perhaps the weakest point is how it
is used
a damaged survey must be completed
before the tornado's
rank can be assigned unlike what
hollywood wants you to believe
you cannot see a tornado and immediately
call out its f scale rank
dr fujita's work was pioneering and his
legacy lives on the groundbreaking work
of his students
in 2007 the fujita scale was upgraded to
the new
enhanced vegeta scale the ef scale
upgrade
was implemented to correct some of these
issues its goal was to standardize the
original scale and remove some of its
ambiguity
the ef scale expanded on the original by
adding in
28 separate damage indicators that could
be used by the surveyors
to more accurately estimate wind speeds
so for example
the new scale allowed for the comparison
of damage between hardwood
and a softwood tree it also had new
categories for different styles of
buildings
damage to a building like a walmart
would be different when compared to a
fast food restaurant
or a three-story apartment building or a
strip mall or an automotive showroom
each of these is now included in the new
scale
one of the bigger issues was in the
change
of the wind speed thresholds for each
level of the new ef scale
an f5 tornado produced winds in excess
of 261 miles an hour
in ef5 you'd only have winds of 200
miles an hour
on may 3 1999 the most powerful tornado
in recorded history blast through moore
oklahoma
a mobile doppler radar called the
doppler on wheels
measured winds of 301 miles an hour plus
or minus about 20 miles an hour
this tornado easily achieved an f5
rating as it completely swept homes off
of their foundations
this was the last tornado to be given an
f5 rating
eight years and one day later a powerful
supercell
thunderstorm formed in kansas its
northeast track targeted the town of
greensburg kansas
this small town had a population close
to 1500 people
it was textbook it had a large forward
flank and a well-defined hook echo
it was also after sunset storm spotters
have great difficulty spotting tornadoes
after dark
raider meteorologists at the national
weather service were the only people
who could still see this storm after
dark
warnings went out for the town of
greensburg and the people took
shelter this picture shows what the city
looked like before the tornado hit
this is the same scene after it passed
to my amazement only 11 people lost
their lives that night
the advance warnings guided by doppler
radar saved
thousands of lives damage assessment
crews from the national weather service
noted that 95
of the structures in the town had been
damaged
they ranked the tornado as an ef5 the
first
five ranked tornado on the new scale
although greensburg has since been
rebuilt in a sustainable and
modern way less than half of the
population resides there now
a lot of tornado research has been has
been conducted
on the basis of increasing the tornado
warning time
since 2010 the average warning time is
exceeded
20 minutes and in some cases 30 minutes
some research has suggested that
extending this time beyond 30 minutes
may not be a good thing the concern is
that extending the warning time may
cause it to
lose its immediacy if it became normal
for tornado warnings to have a 30 to 45
minute lead time
people may not decide to take cover
right away
instead they may make the decision that
may put them
in harm's way in the blockbuster movie
twister from 1996
the main characters are a group of storm
chasers their mission
is to place an instrument pack called
dorothy in the path of a tornado
dorothy would then release hundreds of
small sensors into the storm
that would collect and radio back
information about the storm
well the idea was taken from the
research of dr
lou wicker from the university of
illinois in 1982 lou and his colleagues
designed
toto total tornado observatory
lou's research was abandoned though due
to the difficulty of getting such
an instrument in the path of a tornado
plus it did not have small sensors
connected to soda cantilevers
seeing into the tornado is now done with
high
resolution radar tornado research took a
giant leap forward
when dr josh werman designed the first
doppler on wheels
the idea was to strap a raider onto the
back of a truck and get it as close to
the storm as possible and
scan it storm chasing has been a hobby
for
many people for decades but the
invention of the mobile doppler radar
took storm chasing to a new
level numerous federally funded field
campaigns
like vortex vortex 2 and vortex
southeast
have used doppler on wheels to safely
scan tornadoes from a nearby location
in fact these raiders have participated
in over 20
field studies since they were first
designed
the data collected by these radars has
revolutionized our understanding of
tornadoes
and lengthened warning times these
observations have helped us better model
these storms
and forecast them however at the same
time that tornado research has blossomed
so is the prevalence of amateur storm
chasing
let me mention some key precautions to
keep yourself safe
should you or anyone you know decide to
try storm chasing
always have a point of contact someone
who knows where you are
know your road network never chase on
dirt roads or roads that go
into forested areas you can get stuck or
find yourself in a position
where you can't see the tornado always
bring a cell phone that has access to
radar imagery
there are great radar apps that you can
use that will show you
your position with respect to the
storm's position
always have an out know exactly where
you will go if things get too intense
never try to be a hero keep your
distance
stay to the south east of the storm and
enjoy the view
and whether you're a storm chaser out
chasing or simply
caught in your car when a tornado
strikes there are some basic things you
should know
to stay safe as possible if you're in an
area where there is a nearby shelter or
building abandon your car
and get to the shelter immediately but
what if you are
on an open road should you hide under an
overpass
should you get into a ditch
never take shelter under an overpass
while it may look like a sturdy
structure do not get out of your car and
hide
under a bridge hiding in the supports
under the bridge puts you in a very
vulnerable situation
first the winds of the trundle increase
with height by
climbing up into the bridge supports you
are actually exposing yourself to higher
wind speeds
second the winds of the trailer are
forced to squeeze through the
area under the bridge and are therefore
much faster in this location
finally debris is often found lodged
in the area where you would take shelter
where the ground
kind of meets the overpass above people
have been found
crushed to death there by flying debris
now i was taught when i was younger to
abandon a car and seek shelter in a
nearby ditch
this is no longer advised modern cars
have many safety features that are
designed to keep passengers from injury
airbags seat belts safety glass and
crumple zones protect the occupants
stay in your car if you find if you
cannot find
shelter nearby a weak tornado may
produce 110 mile an hour
winds while these winds can push your
car around and possibly roll it over
i would much rather be in the car than
outside and have to deal with these same
winds
if you're outside on the ground your car
might roll over
while you are hanging onto some grass in
the ditch
plus if the tornado is strong enough to
throw your car
it will pull you right out of the ditch
and throw you too
fema is very clear on their website
ready.gov
that the new protocol is to stay in your
vehicle
tornadoes are a part of life for many
around the world
just like with most things we fear
understanding the tornado in its parent
storm the supercell
is half the battle in staying safe and
losing our fears
you can now use the radar technology i
have taught you to know exactly where
the most dangerous parts of these storms
are found you can use the tools we have
discussed to predict
where they are forecast to form and
monitor
the atmosphere conditions that are
conducive to supercell formation
turn your fear into fascination
and use your knowledge to stay safe
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
you